hola disentis de Latino America Soy Sal
Khan, fundador de la Academia Kahn sin fines de lucro
, como probablemente saben, tenemos la
gran misión de brindar una
educación gratuita de clase mundial para cualquier persona en
cualquier lugar y sabemos que las
personas más importantes en ese  misión eres tú
el maestro y es por eso que, desde el
principio, Khan Academy siempre ha trabajado en
estrecha colaboración con los maestros para poder
crear herramientas para que los maestros
puedan usarlas con sus alumnos y permitir que
los estudiantes aprendan lo mejor
posible y así  es por eso que estamos
emocionados de que seas parte de esta
capacitación porque siempre he dicho que si
tuviera que elegir entre un maestro
increíble y una tecnología increíble, elegiría al
maestro increíble cada vez que lo
bueno es que no tenemos  para hacer esa
compensación y aquí en Khan Academy
estamos tratando de crear herramientas para ti herramientas
que harán tu vida más fácil que
te ahorrarán tiempo y te ayudarán a
servir mejor a tus estudiantes por lo que Khan
Academy es una educación en línea  Todo el conjunto de
recursos es una combinación de
contenido de clase mundial que abarca desde el
jardín de infantes hasta el grado 12
y, en algunos casos, el primer y segundo
año de la universidad
y luego abarca muchas materias.
Hay dos piezas que creo que lo
hacen único.  uno no es solo contenido de clase mundial,
sino que se enseña de una manera que es
muy fácil de entender, también construimos
muchos de los que llamamos
elementos de aprendizaje social y emocional en la plataforma
porque aprender es difícil, puede ser
intimidante, podría sentirse bajo confianza  podría
sentirse poco inteligente aprendiendo algo
que es muy nuevo para usted, por lo que nuestro producto de
contenido y software, la combinación de
ambos, tratamos de hacerlo para que sea fácil de
entender que es divertido, que es
atractivo, que lo motiva y que
ayuda a construir su auto-  confianza para
que pueda comenzar a ser un
aprendiz independiente automotivado para ser un
aprendiz de por vida y lo que nos hace únicos son
esos elementos no solo del contenido
sino también del social-  el aprendizaje emocional es parte
del software, así como tenemos
mucha inteligencia incorporada para saber exactamente
dónde se encuentra y todos los pasos que
necesita aprender, por lo que tenemos esta cosa
llamada mapa de conocimiento dentro de nuestro
producto que le permite decir Dios mío  si
quiero aprender cálculo algún día, primero necesito conocer
estos elementos fundamentales y
luego puedo construir encima como una
casa, tenemos los elementos fundamentales
y luego sabes cómo construir el primer
piso y luego pones el segundo piso
y  conectamos todos esos puntos para usted
nuestro alcance en nuestra escala hoy estamos en
más de ciento noventa países en
todo el mundo somos traducidos a
más de 30 idiomas en todo el mundo por
increíbles defensores voluntarios que
nos ayudan a hacer esto porque creen mucho
en  nuestra misión y realmente se necesita un
pueblo para que eso
suceda, es desafortunado, existe una
idea errónea de que queremos reemplazar
al maestro, absolutamente no, no hay
forma de que podamos reemplazar a un maestro t
Para nosotros, son una parte tan importante de la vida de los estudiantes. Se trata de
proporcionar herramientas y funcionalidades para que
los docentes los capaciten y les den la
oportunidad de ser mejores de lo que jamás
podrían ser. Ser más eficientes. Ser más
efectivos.
puedo hacer para ayudar al maestro para que
pueda ser lo mejor que pueda para
estos estudiantes
la gente de Khan Academy es increíble Me
siento muy bendecido de dirigir esta empresa
porque tengo
más de doscientas personas cuyo único objetivo es permitir
para que esta misión suceda, solo quieren
transformar realmente la
industria educativa para ayudar realmente a esos
niños desatendidos y eso es lo
que comen, respiran y duermen todos los días, por lo
que estamos emocionados de que seas parte de esta
capacitación, esperamos que encuentres
todo lo que somos.  podemos proporcionarle
para que sea de utilidad y
esperamos recibir sus comentarios sobre
cómo juntos podemos servirle mejor a usted y a
sus estudiantes gracias